we have seen examples like 98 times 97
where both numbers were below the base
the technique to multiply numbers like
this was very simple find the base find
the deviations find the sum of any of
the diagonal numbers find the product
and bingo we have our answer and there's
just one thing we need to keep in mind
here the number of digits on the right
will be equal to the number of zeros in
the base but what if both the numbers
were above the base let's say we have to
multiply 12 with 13 as both the numbers
are close to 10 let's consider 10 as the
base once we find the base we need to
find the deviations of the numbers from
the base 12 minus 10 will give us the
deviation of this number from the base
that will be 2 and 13 minus 10 will give
us the deviation of this number from the
base 3 and then we make the partition on
the left we write the sum of any two of
the diagonal numbers and on the right we
write the product of the deviations so
on the left it will be 12 plus 3 or 13
plus 2 15 and on the right we will have
2 times 3 which equals 6 so we write a 6
on the right remember the number of
digits on the right will be equal to the
number of zeros in the base-10 hence one
digit 12 times 13 is 156 with the same
technique try multiplying 102 with 104
as both
numbers are close to 100 let's take
hundred as the base here the deviation
of 100 to from 100 is 2 and that of 104
from 100 is for some on the left and the
product on the right 102 plus 4 is 106
and 2 times 4 is 8
but wait as there are 2 zeros in the
base the number of digits on the right
will be 2 so we write 0 8 and not 8 102
times 104 will equal 10 thousand six
hundred and eight you have to realize
how simple this technique is just four
simple steps base deviations sum and
product that's it
why don't you try another one take a
simpler one this time 15 times 19 as
both the numbers are close to 10 let's
make 10 as the base here 15 minus 10 is
5 and 19 minus 10 is 9 some on the left
and product on the right 15 plus 9 is 24
and 9 times 5 is 45 but as the number of
zeros in the base is 1 we can have just
one digit on the right the 4 or 45 has
to be carried over we write 45 like this
and then we add 5 8 to 15 times 19 is
285 the only tricky part in this
technique is the number of digits you
are allowed on the right once you master
that it gets very easy base deviations
sum and product we will try out a few
more interesting examples of this type
in the next session
you